Kyle Margot Robbie met Ellen ah it's a
it's a it's probably a story too long to
tell right now but honestly you could
just Google Margot Robbie on Ellen and
probably um you can get the whole long
story how old is Margot Robbie I'm 28.
although I see you on the internet a lot
of people being like 28 more like 38 and
I'm like oh I mean I can show you my
birth certificate I really am how was
America Robbie discovered I wasn't
discovered as much as I forced my way
onto a job essentially because I just
wouldn't stop calling Fremantle media
which is the company that runs neighbors
hail Margaret Robbie Brooklyn accent how
Hell Margaret Robbie Brooklyn a house
that makes no sense no it doesn't how
much well um yes yeah the short answer
is pretended to have fake nails how to
get Margot Robbie waves
what like hair waves I I never do it
myself I do I just have it in a plot the
night before and take it out